I diagnosed with Lyme disease in several colonfections several years ago. I've done several rounds of a few different antibiotics over a period of two years.
I most likely have had in phase three Lyme for a while. So obviously this person is reading our information on Lyme because I came up with that phase three, phase three Lyme is when you're in an autoimmune condition.
You may not even have a presence of any active antigen, the living organism, the Borrelia, the colonfections may not even be physically present in that person's body anymore.
But what those things have done is sparked the production of self antibody. So the person has antibodies to self tissue.
That is to have an autoimmune disease. That's what's called phase three Lyme.
I've done many supplements in homeopathics over the years. Now I know not to take the immune boosted ones. So of course, you don't take immune boosted supplements at all if you have an autoimmune disease because when you stimulate your immune system, if you have antibodies to self tissue, what are you going to do?
You're going to kill that which you have antibodies against first, which is your self.
I've done daily rife treatments for six months and infrared sauna. I've eaten a clean organic gluten, a dairy free diet for years. I've done follow kidney and liver cleanses along with colonics.
I've done a lot of things over the years. I've not seen much improvement and seemed to be getting worse. The live doctor I was seeing and working with in Wisconsin retired.
My main symptoms are raging eggs and arms and legs joint pain in these brain fog lack of energy occasional sensitive skin. What would you suggest?
When you have pain in your extremities that tends to move around, when you have brain fog, when you have lack of energy sensitivity in your skin that tends to move around. It's not like I have sensitivity at this one spot right here between my thumb and my finger.
When you have that loss of sensitivity there, then you know it's probably a peripheral nerve issue damage the peripheral nerve that feeds that area right there.
When it moves around, you have this weird sensitivity of your skin that's different. It's not constant. It can be in different spaces along with these other symptoms as a person pointed out.
Most likely you're dealing with inflammation that's in the brain itself. If you have damage in the brain, if you have inflammation that's in the brain, it's going to affect where those neurons are going or it's going to affect.
So if I have in the pride alone of my brain, that's my sensory part of the brain. Left and right pride alobs, your left pride alone controls the sensory is getting communication with the sensory on the right side of the body and vice versa.
If I have inflammation in my right pride alone today, then I could have sensory issues in my left side of my body.
Hey, hot and cold sensation, weird tingling, you know, all sorts of weird any type of sensory issues.
So it's it's very common that post live disease post vaccine injury post heavy mental toxicity post concussion that we end up with inflammation in the brain.
The inflammation in the brain, long-term, could lead to damage to the brain's immune system called the microglial cells. That's called microglial private.
At worst case scenario, you could have you could end up developing antibodies to neural tissue.
So you can't really test for microglial private that really has to do with the coordination of subjective findings.
But you can test for auto antibodies to neural tissue. That is a Syrex Array 7x test.
So that's what I would recommend for a person. They came to me with this condition. I'd say let's get a Syrex Array 7x. Also, I probably get a Syrex Array 5 because that test for other antibodies.
Again, in a person's I suspect reading your information that I have an autoimmune disease. I suspect that I'm in phase 3 live.
Okay, but what antibodies do you have? What self antibodies are we dealing with?
Because that's how you would do it and you know, work up a treatment plan for the person.
The person has no neurological antibodies, but let's say they have anti-body, you have rheumatoid factor or something.
Okay, so you're at an early stage of rheumatoid arthritis. Then you want to be looking for different triggers that are going to be affecting that, which may be very different than what could be affecting neurological antibodies.
So the first thing would be to get a more proper diagnosis, and that would be to get some anti-body testing, trying to suggest getting a Syrex Array 5 and a Syrex Array 7x.
If those are all clean, that would be a really good thing. And that would tell us that we could dial it back a little bit that we're dealing with.
We don't still have, you know, horrible symptoms, but it's probably due to microbial primate.
I do have a good video on that. I mentioned that multiple times in the holistic health hour.
If you go to our website, cuttersclinic.com, and you search Bureau, Bureau, inflammation, Bureau, inflammation.
You'll see a video. It's about a half hour long video, and it does go through some care options with that, too.
I maybe start with that. And I suspect you're probably on one of our courses, unless you've just read my books, so you can do to understand autoimmune disease.
But I highly recommend our autoimmune product disease and autoimmune disease, as well.